in our world wind up going bankrupt in
the government world they just keep
writing checks hi I'm Ted bellacor with
reason TV and today i'll be speaking
with ray griggs Griggs is the director
of the new documentary I want your money
which hits theaters October 15 ray tell
me about your film I created documentary
about two views you can take capitalism
versus socialism taking two iconic
presidents Ronald Reagan and Obama and
contrasting these two views when the
viewer goes to see your film what can he
or she expect her to interview what kind
of stories do tell I did get notable
interviewees of people that you
recognize that have real good knowledge
about what they're talking about and you
can back it up and say you know what
that's right people like Mike Huckabee
newt gingrich john stossel when an
audience member comes out what do you
hope here is she remembers i hope that
you get away with a new understanding
definition of capitalism and the beauty
of our country and realizing the massive
debt that we're accumulating in concrete
terms what might happen if we don't
write this ship it's beyond what you can
think of as bankruptcy that's the beauty
in our world is you're only allowed so
much money and then you end up going
bankrupt in the government world they
just keep writing checks that we can't
sustain we have to ultimately be
responsible for it you talk about 13
trillion dollars of debt in the brief
conversation we just started talking
about right now we've already spent two
million dollars I mean it's literally
going every 60 seconds two and a half
million dollars we have to be held
accountable for that a collapse of our
country or whether just losing all the
freedoms that we have today that you
know of us as the free market capitalism
will allow or whether it's just
completely high insane taxes you just
can't afford to better your lifestyle or
do anything you want to do in life
because you're breaking your back every
day just to try to pay your taxes alone
it's an interesting topic because on the
one hand you do have a lot of folks who
are upset about it but on the other it's
sort of ephemeral to a lot of people
like so the debt is growing but it's
been growing for a long time those are
people not paying taxes people who don't
pay into taxes they want more and more
and more as long as it benefits them I'm
sure they're going to vote for it the
problem is debt what's your solution one
is we got to get to a balanced budget
the others we gotta control
as sad as it sounds we've got to
eliminate some of these entitlement
programs as you know Reagan is said it
best these entitlement programs as
closest thing you'll ever experience to
Eternity because they don't in you have
a ride up in the New York Times you're
going to be opening in five hundred
theaters all these things are very
unusual for a documentary filmmaker not
named Michael Moore yeah so how did you
do it with this very different message
that's a tough one answer I'd say you
know obviously God is I believe in God
he's I feel he's in my corner but I feel
I created something reaching out to the
people and there just happened to be
talking about because it's on their
minds I think timing has something to do
with it a little bit timing is
especially interesting in this case it
opens October 15th a couple weeks before
the midterm election that was a struggle
because and you know I had just finished
the documentary and I was trying to get
it out before the midterm elections
because it's very timed it's concerning
the midterm elections you know I want
people to go in and take back the house
I wonder if you have any worries about
the FEC in 2008 there was the very
famous case of Hillary the movie I was
halted on the grounds that it was coming
out right before the Democratic
primaries since then we've had the
Citizens United decision which was a
victory for free speech although highly
controversial to a lot of people where
does that leave you in your film I like
to play chess so in my life I i like to
think like chess and always think ahead
I've already applied to the FEC about
getting approval than shown previous
cases of how Hillary was eventually
proved in fahrenheit 911 was approved
nothing in our film is pushing one
certain candidate or looking at trying
to endorse some political event were
merely speaking the fact about debt if
the story is about debt then there's
plenty of blame to go around exactly in
terms of crap Republican exactly because
I don't even let Bush off the hook he
drove that debt up like crazy he did
lower taxes but again he spent like a
drunken sailor after the midterm
elections everybody's assuming the
Republicans are going to gain a lot of
ground what's to prevent them from just
falling into the same bad habits that I
did before I would like to think that a
lot of Republicans today that are
running are paying attention what's go
went on and realizing what the people
are speaking like the tea parties and
all these other people are speaking out
about and say you know what I need to
get back to the old traditional
conservative values okay and control
spending and so I'd like to believe that
the ones that are running now today are
taking a lot of this in consideration
and are going to make a change most
documentaries tend toward the liberal
direction you're a conservative
filmmaker did you have any problems with
that in the development of your film it
wasn't as easy getting crew together as
you think you had to find like-minded
people just to run your camera or run
your sound equipment they'd want to know
about documentary and you tell them
about it and then they're like hmm I'll
tell you what if I'll work on it as long
as my name isn't attached to it because
I'm not going to ruin my career believe
me I actually really got responses like
that you got all these battles when
you're taking on a conservative
documentary I think that can change if
more and more people get behind it I
think there should be just the equal
conservative documentaries as there is
liberals Michael Moore I mean the man's
a genius he's capitalized on the left
the man-made 220 million dollars off
fahrenheit 911 you can't deny his
success of the way he pulls his
documentary films in a lot of people
have their problems with Michael Moore
out you know I certainly have mine with
how he makes his films but I guess what
you're saying and it seems to be a good
point at least can we credit him with
maybe getting people used to and
comfortable with the documentary form
whether you like Michael Moore or you
don't you have to give them credit for
being a filmmaker and being able to
entertain the audience and bring in
those dollars and shift to a couple of
your other projects I hear that you
developed an iphone app that was not
shall we say embraced by Apple right you
turn it on it senses your GPS location
and within seconds they'll tell you who
your congressman is and give you their
phone number in their email address and
then if you didn't like your bill that
they voted on or whatever you shake your
phone their head bobbles they rejected
it due to the caricature of it did they
say why was it not respectful of their
high office they had a character Nancy
Pelosi and they came back and said you
know we just don't approve it is because
of the news and the attention and
everything at got they end up you know
looking at it and resending it and put
it back on Apple what's it called its
called Bob
up if you go to the website of I want
your money you'll see a link that goes
right to it and you can download it tell
me about your wind in the willows
project it was a famous story back in
1908 by Kenneth Grahame what I want to
do and when in the willow says I want to
go back again old school and take what's
called animatronics it's not CG
animation it's not claymation it's not
cartoon animation it's basically robots
if you think of it that way puppeteered
robots and I want to take future
technology and bring that up to speed
and create new innovative ways to
explore those type of creatures in our
test for example mole he has over 58
servos inside the head these are gears
and motors that make it run and moving
he could do things with his face that
the human can so it looks pretty
astonishing
you